Apple was the only Mega tech company
that didn't drive most of their revenue
from software and services but over the
past several years this has been rapidly
changing the reality is that smartphones
have hit a plateau and apple can only
introduce the next iPhone that's better
than ever before and increase the price
so many times in fact I believe that
it's just a matter of time until Apple
drops the number naming scheme on the
iPhone before you know it the new iPhone
will be called the 2027 iPhone as
opposed to the iPhone 19. this will no
doubt reduce the hype surrounding iPhone
launches but that's okay by then Apple
will not only PS operate giant but it
will be a full-on software company there
are iPhones Macs iPads and watches will
simply be a vehicle to sell their real
money producers subscriptions and
services